One morning in August 1968,
factory worker Wang Xiaoping overheard
news of a mysterious mandatory meeting.
Rumors whispered through the cafeteria
described shipments of a gift
from the country’s communist leader,
Chairman Mao Zedong.
And sure enough, managers soon dispersed
a gift to every factory worker—
a glass box encasing
a golden wax replica of a mango.
Wang Xiaoping’s factory wasn’t the only
facility to receive this unusual offering.
The Chairman gifted fresh mangoes
to factories across China,
leading employees to stay up late,
touching the fruits and contemplating
the meaning behind Mao's gesture.
Some tried to preserve
the fresh mangoes in formaldehyde,
while others ate the fruit
and commissioned wax replicas
of their prize.
In one factory, workers initiated
a strange ritual:
peeling and boiling their mangoes
to create a “holy” broth
that was spooned into their mouths.
Since traditional Chinese medicine often
involved boiling ingredients,
it's possible this mango wine was
concocted as a kind of healing tonic.
Soon, fables formed that the fruit
ensured a long life
like the Peaches of Immortality
from Chinese mythology.
And by refusing to eat
the mangoes himself,
Mao had generously sacrificed his own
longevity for the working class.
But whatever Mao's intentions,
this mango mania wasn’t as frivolous
as it might seem.
And in fact, it’s harmless appearance
hid a much darker truth.
Two years earlier, Mao Zedong had launched
the Cultural Revolution,
a decade-long political and ideological
movement intended to erase
capitalist thought and cultural traditions
from Chinese society.
To enact this plan,
Mao called on the Red Guards,
a student-led paramilitary group.
He enlisted them to help eradicate
the “Four Olds”—
a vaguely defined set
of customs, habits, and ideas
often associated
with the elite upper-class.
Mao’s dogma was militant,
and the Red Guard interpreted his vision
as achievable only through violence.
The Red Guard acted above law and order,
ransacking temples and tombs,
including those of dynastic royalty
and Confucius.
Homes were raided and piles
of books burned in the streets.
But the Red Guard’s rampage went
far beyond property damage.
They began holding “struggle sessions”—
public spectacles designed to shame
so-called class enemies.
Victims were accused of holding
elitist, capitalist values,
and were often forced to wear heavy
signs detailing their crimes.
The Red Guard pressured people
to accuse their friends and family.
They manipulated students to denounce
their teachers and parents.
They gradually morphed
into torture and executions.
After two years of the Red Guards’ chaos,
Mao recanted his support
and sent 30,000 factory workers to fight
the Red Guard at Qinghua University.
With the help of the
People’s Liberation Army,
these factory workers succeeded,
and Mao thanked them for their service
with a crate of 40 mangoes.
This gesture wasn’t quite as generous
as it appeared
since Mao was actually passing
along a gift
he received from Pakistan’s
foreign minister.
But much worse, this reward was quickly
tainted by the ideology
of the Cultural Revolution.
As a propaganda tool, Mao’s mangoes
demanded high levels of respect.
Workers boarded unheated buses
in sub-zero temperatures to visit
mandatory mango exhibitions
organized by the government.
Factory workers were scolded
for not holding their replicas securely.
And in Sichuan, a man who remarked
that the mango was “nothing special”
and “looked like a sweet potato”
was arrested, tried, and executed.
For reasons mostly unknown, the mango
fever broke a year and a half later.
After the Red Guard was dissolved
and participants were sent
to the countryside for re-education,
the mystifying mango faded
from official propaganda.
Wax from the replicas were repurposed
for candles during power outages.
And today you’d be lucky to find
an antique mango tray or medallion
while perusing a Beijing flea market.
But the tale of Mao’s mangoes
is just a minor story
amidst a decade
of painful, buried history.
Discussion of the Cultural Revolution
is restricted across China.
And though some former Red Guards have
attempted to challenge this policy
by publicly reflecting and apologizing
for their actions,
they still avoid maligning Mao Zedong.
Given the current political
landscape of China,
only time will tell when this history
will be discussed openly and freely.